هو حاكم فلوريدا الجمهوري وهو المنافس
الرئيسي لدونالد ترامب يصنف ديسنتوس او
يصنف ديسانتس نفسه على انه محافظ على غرار
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب لكن من دون
اخطائه
وتتمثل فكره ديسانتوس للترشح في ان لديه
سجلا حافلا من الانجازات المتعلقه بالقيم
المحافظه والتي حققها خلال مسيرته
السياسيه فقد سند سانتوس قوانين محافظه
رفيعه المستوى لتسهيل امتلاك السلاح
وتقييد تعليم الهويه الجنسيه في المدارس
وتشديد قواعد التصويت في الانتخابات والحد
من عمليات الاجهاض
واشار ديسانتوس ايضا الى استعداده لمواجهه
الشركات الكبرى التي يرى انها تقدم اجنده
ليبراليه في حال كسب الانتخابات
كما يطرح قضيه انه يفوز دائما ولم يهزم في
سباقات الكونجرس او لمنصب حاكم فلوريدا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات